The Guardian has grown from being a British
newspaper to being one of the largest English
language news sources on the planet.
The Guardian products work across the entire
globe but we’re really keen on taking this
even further.
We’re extremely excited about the growth
in space travel and space tourism and our
UX engineering and design team are now looking
at how we can take the fantastic experiences
you find on Earth and get them to work even
if you’re not on Earth, if you’re in orbit,
if you’re on the moon or on a trip to Mars.
Whilst testing our designs on Earth we developed
a system called Astro UI.
We’ve brought this into all of our UX flows.
The gloves of the extra vehicular mobility
unit are much larger, we needed to design
some new icons, floating action buttons specifically
and we used the updated material design guidelines
for this.
Another challenge in space is gravity or the
lack of gravity.
Using the principles of motion we created
a system called Fixed Point View - no matter
which way the phone is orientated, the articles,
the videos, the images will automatically
align to the viewer.
There are regular Android APIs that are very
helpful in space flight; one in particular
is the text-to-speech API.
In space there are times when you can’t
easily look at the screen so ‘Read it to
me’ is especially useful.
Astronauts can then have an article read in
their helmets when they’re on the moon for
example.
The testing is really important because we
need to understand what works and what doesn’t
work in space.
In the Google Play Developer Console there’s
a new feature called hangout with expert.
Hi.
Hey, this is Captain Mark Kelly, how do you
guys hear me
This allows us to have face to face access
anytime with the space beta tester, either
on the Earth or in space.
Being in space is a bit like being underground.
Sometimes the data is really expensive and
sometimes not there at all.
Our APKs are as lightweight as possible, so
that they can be really easily installed;
then when they are running, we cache as much
content as possible.
Innovation sits at the heart of what the teams
at The Guardian do, but it’s all for a purpose;
that purpose is getting our journalism into
readers’ hands and now those experiences
extend not just everywhere on Earth but beyond
it as well.
Android and Google Play are parts of us achieving
that.